if you've ever seen a commercial for the
home depot you might be familiar with
this tune it's a good time to be a doer
home depot and its theme song have
inspired a wave of videos on social
media
revealing its cultural status as the
go-to home improvement store for many
during the pandemic
home depot is the world's largest home
improvement retailer with over 2 300
stores across north america
what we've seen is home price
appreciation and housing activity
at unprecedented levels and what we know
is that when homes become more valuable
those homeowners are more willing to
spend on them with its 2021 fiscal year
sales larger than both lowe's and ace
hardware combined one of home depot's
biggest advantages is its foothold in
the professional customer space that is
electricians remodelers plumbers and
other home professionals that place more
lucrative orders so how exactly has home
depot attracted more professional
customers and what other strategies have
helped it become a leader in the home
improvement retail industry
this is the economics of home depot
walk into a home depot you'll see a huge
floor space dozens of long aisles with
everything from screws and other
hardware to tools to major appliances
garden supplies doors windows toilets
really anything you need for a home
improvement project a typical home depot
store stocks about thirty thousand to
forty thousand items throughout the year
most locations are around one hundred
four thousand square feet the scale of
the store gives customers the
opportunity to buy raw materials in bulk
and pick up items quickly they try to be
somewhere that you can go if you're just
an individual trying to fix up something
in your kitchen they also try to be a
place that you can go if you're a
contractor trying to
buy lumber to help renovate somebody's
home or if you're a plumber that needs
all kinds of pipe fittings so they
really try to
be a good source on both sides of that
equation home depot began when
co-founders bernie marcus and arthur
blank were fired from a home improvement
company called handy dance they wanted
to launch a store that would be
significantly bigger and cheaper than
competitors in 1979 they opened their
first two home depot locations in
atlanta the home depot the founders had
a vision for a home improvement retailer
that could be a one-stop shop for the
diy or do-it-yourself customer you've
never seen anything like it the home
improvement customer to us is unique
they're a doer that's where that word
comes from since its founding home depot
has grown into a multi-billion dollar
company that increasingly caters to the
professional contractor as well as the
diy consumer while many industries like
service and hospitality took a hit
during the pandemic home depot's revenue
continued to grow the pandemic fueled a
boom in the home improvement industry as
people spent more time and money on
remodeling projects between the middle
of 2020 in the middle of 2021
there were four straight quarters where
home depot grew its sales by more than
20 percent year over year it's a very
fast pace for a large established
company home depot says they are seeing
increasing demand for professional
projects as people feel comfortable
inviting contractors back into their
homes there's been this buildup of
projects uh that require professionals
that more recently people have been
willing to get to and that sort of led
to a second wind of sales growth what
kind of person would come here at 5 45
a.m well
there's carly a carpenter home depot has
positioned itself to attract more
business from these contractors and home
professionals particularly ones that
place big orders everything we do
we do for them in the 2021 fiscal year
about 50 percent of its sales came from
pro customers even though they made up
less than 10 of its customer base in
comparison about 20 to 25 percent of
lowe's total sales come from pro
customers according to the company as a
key part of its pro customer strategy
home depot has invested 1.2 billion
dollars in expanding its supply chain
and distribution network the company
says it is building 150 new distribution
centers to help speed up the
replenishment of store shelves and
quickly deliver purchases to customers
doors each facility with some as large
as about 14 professional football fields
can hold a huge amount of inventory and
deliver orders directly to a project
site one thing we know that's important
to our pros
is delivery of product to the job site
we've shifted our model to a network of
nearly 150 distribution centers that are
engineered to deliver those big and
bulky products that are unique to the
home depot and unique to the pro think
lumber think doors think windows think
vanities we're designing a network that
will deliver those goods same day or
next day to 90 percent of the population
in our market the home improvement
giant's distribution network works in
tandem with their online strategy giving
pro customers more flexible options that
better align with busy schedules we're
one of the largest e-commerce retailers
in the country by volume when people
come to pick up orders from our lockers
or from our service desk they often shop
for more products in the store and so
that's an economic flywheel that our
website creates for our company these
possibilities have really helped the
company grow its sales quite a bit over
the last two years
sales from e-commerce channels have gone
up by about 100 so basically doubled
though home depot has seen a long period
of consistent revenue growth the home
improvement retail space remains a
competitive and fragmented market this
is a space where
customers are very sensitive to prices
so if one brand is charging a higher
price for a certain type of equipment
that's something that buyers could pick
up on and could easily shift to another
retailer so home depot is definitely
very
sensitive to other big chains to smaller
mom and pop stores the industry is also
sensitive to economic fluctuations
especially with spending trends tied to
the housing market going back to the
great recession and the financial crisis
10 years ago that was a very difficult
time for home improvement retailers a
turbulent period for home depot in the
last couple years during the pandemic
that housing market's been very strong
certainly a company that would be in a
very different position if there was
some kind of big downturn in the housing
market in general
[Music]